bonjour parce qu'on vous parle de choses
sérieuses mais qu'on se prend pas au
sérieux et parce que le rire c'est bon
pour la santé
on va vous parler du festival de
l'humour bienvenue sur 9 7 4 tv bonsoir
messieurs
alors vous vous êtes les comics associé
avec deux cas avec deux cas mais en fait
le s à la fin il est toujours facultatif
mais tout le monde le prononce en fait
je vous donne le sein pas vraiment ça
fait comme ça parce qu'au départ on
s'appelle les comics associé à comic ou
bien elles sont toutes les télévisions
d'appel comique se faisaient très
nombreux c'est pour ça pendant en fait
pourquoi x et américaine ne craignant ni
good et vous faites du stand up
voilà oui il y en a qui font du scanner
parce que en fait faut dire que les
comics associés ou les comics à associer
c'est un collectif en fait c'est un
collectif de d'artistes c'est des
individus qui sont contre et qui au fond
d'eux groupe est bon chacun dans son
style quoi notre sueur plus terral de
toit plus ce stand up à reprenant 2 3 ni
jeune groupe de plus de fantaisie
musique
d'accord on n'a pas les mêmes
compétences à nous le dire mais ce que
tout le monde fait rire oui les paroles
qui ne joue pas et qu'ils voient
comment dire faire tout le monde fait
rire oui mais pas pareil sedan en fait
il y en a un qui est vraiment plus drôle
que les autres c'est qui celui-là est
donc énergie spontanéité c'est ça que
vous utilisez c'est ça votre registre
d'énergie beaucoup
non mais en fait nous une face ici je
peux te tutoyer ou huawei plaisir mais
je te tutoie alors d'accord alors si tu
veux bien oui en fait double ce le
chauffer mais personne n'a donc ce que
nous fait sa une chose c'est pas un
c'est pas un spectacle ou un moment
donné tu vas voir des noirs dedans
facile bien calé dans la matinée dans un
sinan à des noirs mais en fait baptisé
de l'obscur mais je m'en fous moi je
parle avec des termes techniques les
gants ce que tu non mais l'écart et
c'est comme ça depuis 10h30 01 être
utilisées nous par contre non non mais
c'est juste qu'il faut en donner envie
aux gens nous mêmes nous on se bat non
journée l'esprit de groupe
d'accord l'esprit de douala unis comme
les doigts gréco ans et n importe quoi
on ça nous énerve c'est un spectacle
effectuons il peut y avoir des noirs
c'est pas le problème il faut voir c'est
pas un spectacle du klu klux klan mais
l'accord tout le monde peut venir tous
des blancs kan en personne parle voilà
mais tu veux faire intégrer notre parce
que depuis le début tu as des vannes
vraiment on dirait un prêtre tamoul pour
le nouvel-an quoi vraiment c'est à vous
ni à quelque chose j'ai n'hésite pas à
aider semoun avec les 7 chevaux ici
alors est ce que cette dure jusqu'à
arabes sont re devient c'est un petit
bol
de faire sa place qu'on est un jeune
groupe comme ça hop vous avez un
parcours à la télé aussi dans l'impro le
matin est-ce que c'est dur de faire sa
place
le déjà plus difficile de placer
d'accord en fait tenu que les passe de
trois mais bien si vous voulez vue de
façade enlever les jeunes fassent dans
le ville monsieur renard c'est ça c'est
pas facile c'est que ben il faut faire
sa place
il faut il faut montrer de quoi nous
sommes capables c'est et pour enfin
donner envie aussi au public de venir
voir à nous sommes en jeu précise aux
téléspectateurs quand même que l'idée
c'est de représenter le hall du théâtre
départementaux pour montrer qu'il ya une
préparation de ce festival de l'humour
ont donné envie on si c'était vraiment
des grands humoristes on aurait mis des
chaises donc tu vois comme tu nous
alexandre brisé voilà alexandre ne va
pas durer si tu continues
il faut donner des conditions déjà tu
n'en as pas un verre d'eau on a prévu
breschel sont brutalement faut choisir
ce que je vous propose c'est stand up a
peut-être se mettre en situation voir si
les gens ont envie de venir vous voir
voilà la scène est à vous d'accord et je
reviens vous voir juste après alors je
vais je vais faire comme si on y était
alors est ce qu'on peut avoir un peu de
musique genre alors
bonsoir tout le monde comment ça va nous
avons en direct du théâtre de champ
fleuri avec alexandre gilles
mira olivier avec son tee shirt et son
pantalon mieux tout de suite je vous
demande un coeur le premier artiste de
la soirée
brigitte alors brice alors on va voir
parce que j'ai remarqué briest amis des
chaussures spéciales aujourd'hui
ouais en fait j'ai mis mon association
tamis des chaussures soir ils vont
pouvoir envoie ses chaussures au pare
balles et est en fait pourquoi elles
sont beaucoup s en fout c'est ce que ça
veut dire soit dans cette semaine en
fait que ce soit que veut dire que enfin
bien un bébé est-il que le calgary pour
les téléspectateurs qui nous regardent
en fait soit en c1 ces américains trois
américains ont plu parce que ces ricains
et en fait ça veut dire soit en fait ça
fait de la prison ouais mais ça veut
dire en fait si quitely louis aguets en
fait ça veut dire en secret nous sommes
en fait pourquoi venir vous voir
ça y est c'est le moment où tu veux
parler moi je peux dire à moore oui
c'est d'ailleurs pourquoi venu nous voir
parce que la jeunesse elle est là que la
relève elle est là comme dirait le
quotidien donc on a fait des bonds en
première quand même la jeunesse la
relève est là et c'est bondir le
festival de l'humour revient la réunion
dont les amis réunionnais
les lyonnaises venez nous venez
découvrir tous les sens de spectacles ya
devant nous deux mais qu'associé on veut
théâtre concert le 28 avril à 20 heures
donc venez nous voir et les associés
mais venait une fois qu on est le
théâtre de saint-gilles le 29 ans de
10,29 brunémont festival l'union mais
surtout vous voir c'est maintenant le
festival d'humour c'est nous taquin donc
il ya d'autres noms médias donnent mais
faut venir voir en tout cas
plein de bonnes choses pour la suite
bonne route messieurs vous avez bien
compris le message pousser ses portes du
téat départementaux venez au festival
l'humour on se marre bien on peut pas
dire le contraire et à bientôt sur 9 7 4
tv bien avant de raconter sa passion en
fait il a une passion pour les chats ils
aiment tester la solidité des chats
alors là bien là est ce que tu peux nous
raconter comment t'y fais le test en
fait paris bernard mieux en mieux mais
avec la tendresse que tu fais que les
chats en fait aimer prouveur ijaw les
chats il voit tombe toujours seul
capable mais format la moule que l'autre
du malade échappé d'un fond la péter moi
j'aime les animaux
tu peux te raconter un peu quand tu es
allé chercher du boulot comment ça s'est
passé en fait
ah ben moi me dépasser vais partout et
ne marche pas oui mais dépossédé dans
toutes les mairies et à chaque fois
qu'on y arrive dans les mairies bay
- oui mais m'appartient samedi le mall
mary fema dépose mon cv mais si ben
bonjour monsieur voilà j'ai acv et le
monsieur pareil on regarde mais sans moi
c'était qui en fait est qu'il s'était le
maire je me rappelle plus les mares ou
garder masi wi fi d'écouté messieurs
mettez golf il ya plus de travail
oui mais vous m'avez dit oui là non oui
oui mais il ya plus sinon mais je ne
compris pas est-ce qu'il ya travail
parce que vous me dites oui je comprends
pas monsieur oui mais non il ya pas de
travail mais lui continue et comment
donner non pas par un map est un kama
parti c'est un homme en partie de la
pyramide la pyramide inversé la donne
tant qu'il n'avait ni monsieur la même
apathie wali mais si vous me suivez
menacé vs king fmi ni toile à coiffer
tout le monde la regarde pas pareil non
larry devant marc cherry le chef jouer
et après j'ai eu et j'ai touché
j'avais fait des pyramides avec jgc
gravure on va me bouleverser on va me
renvoyer chez lui au pied moi je me
souviens de fou quand même parce que
modèle non la commenceront bimaï peur
parce que l'apathie tampon m'a même pas
dit on pour prôner travail était même
apathie départ on s'est fait la g
appareils pareille date on ya rien
santini pour nicolas nonon ses priorités
au chanteur poète salah dernière moyens
navals mon baquet du soleil merci quand
même
c'est sur ce constat un peu alarmant
c'est vrai voilà n'ont pas de chance
c'est cool et green power
alors maintenant on va essayer avec le
green power en fait si tu veux c'est ce
qu'on véhicule parce qu'enfin vous
couper ce qu'un bon grain ou koné power
que se vêtir wee bb enfin de nous c'est
le grain power en fait je vois c'est
cela et en fait on a écrit de guerre ce
travail